Researchers now believe the purpose of REM sleep is to assist the brain in
growth and development. Do you remember when we previously talked about
neuroplasticity in other lessons? Well, in infancy, our brains are very plastic
and less plastic in old age. We see this correspond with the amount of REM
sleep we get at these different ages. A fascinating component of REM sleep is
that this is when we dream. And while we're dreaming, the areas of our brain
that are responsible for receiving sensory stimulation and responsible for
controlling and planning our body movements are actually activated. This is why
we feel like we're running or swimming or even falling while we're dreaming. In
essence, we feel the dream like it's really happening. Sleep is an adaptive
response and imperative for healthy functioning, both mentally and physically.
If we don't get enough REM sleep one night, we're going to get more REM sleep
the next night. This is called the rebound effect. This shows us, there's both
a biological need for sleeping and REM sleep. Now, let's finish up this
material on sleeping and dreaming with Susan and talk about an area that I find
really fascinating. That's the ability for someone to become consciously aware
while they're dreaming, lucid dreaming.